thanks for joining me on the free pilot
training channel
today we're going to be talking about
class golf which is uncontrolled
airspace
now we've already discussed in detail
all the different types of controlled
air space you need to be aware of to get
your private pilot's license
but you also need to be familiar with
the details of uncontrolled airspace
and here in the united states we call
this class golf
now here in class g airspace air traffic
control has no authority or
responsibility to control air traffic
but there are visual flight rule
minimums that apply in this airspace
we'll take a look at those in just a
second but first let's take a look and
see how we can identify
class golf once again to do this i'm
going to pull out my vfr sectional
by the way guys if you're looking for a
quick reference guide to decipher the
vfr sectional
check out the aeronautical chart user's
guide this is a really quick and easy
way to decipher all the symbols and
stuff you might see on a sectional
i can almost guarantee you you're going
to see questions on this on the verbal
part of your check ride
you can download this for free from the
faa's website to your phone or your ipad
if you remember from the last lesson we
said that in these unmarked areas
class echo starts at 1 200 feet agl
beneath that you'll find class golf and
that starts at the surface and goes
up to but does not include 1200 feet agl
now inside these hazy magenta rings we
said that echo starts at 700 feet agl
and as you've probably already guessed
underneath that you'll find golf
starting at the surface and going up to
but not including 700 feet
remember these hazy blue markings
anytime you see these the class
echo airspace inside of those starts at
500 feet msl so that means the class
golf underneath that
starts at the surface and goes up to but
does not include
14 500 now there is something that i
failed to mention in the last lesson on
class echo airspace
there is a possibility that you may run
into these zippered blue markings
there aren't too many more in the
continental united states and you'll
find most of them now
on the coast these just mean that the
class echo
starts or ends somewhere different than
normal these are super simple though
they tell you exactly where the class
echo airspace starts
on this side of the zipper you can see
that it starts at 1
300 msl then over here the bottom of
echo starts at 2700 msl
then as you might have guessed we've got
class golf underneath there
and it goes up to but does not include
that altitude
so in this case golf starts at the
surface and goes up to 1299 feet msl
so if there's one big takeaway for your
written test remember the bottom of
class
echo has a solid number associated with
it
whether that be 700 agl 1200 agl
14500 msl or another altitude
in all these cases class golf starts the
surface and goes up to but does not
include those altitudes
now as i mentioned in the last lesson
sometimes class delta can revert to
class golf
here we have a small airport near tulsa
that does just that
let's pull off the chart supplement to
get the scoop
once again we'll look down at the line
labeled air space
as you can see the tower operates from
1300 zulu to 0-400 zulu
then all the other times it's class golf
now let's take a look at the part of
class golf that everybody hates
weather minimums i'll try to make this
as easy to remember as possible
first let's look at the class g weather
minimums for 1
200 feet agl or less and on this one
altitude doesn't matter as long as
you're 1200 feet from the surface
so in class g airspace and within 1 200
feet of the surface
during the day all i need is one statute
mile visibility
and clear the clouds clear of clouds
simply means that i can fly right next
to a cloud
as long as i don't touch it now at night
the faa wants you to have a little bit
more separation
so for that one we'll break out our
trusty three cessna 152s
we need three statute miles visibility
we need to stay 500 feet below the
clouds
2 000 from the sides and a thousand from
the tops
now there is one exception to these
nighttime minimums
if you're at 1 200 feet agl or lower
within a half a mile of the runway and
in the traffic pattern
you can go back to using your daytime
vfr minimums
now what are the weather minimums in
class golf over 10 000
msl guess what they're the same as class
echo over 10
000 msl unless of course you're under 1
200 feet agl
if you remember from the last lesson we
need five statute miles visibility
we need to stay a thousand feet below
the clouds one statute mile away from
the sides and a thousand feet from the
tops
now there is a chance you might find
yourself in class golf air space
above 1200 feet agl but below 10
000 feet msl if this happens
you only need one statute mile
visibility but you need the same cloud
clearances
as echo so stay 500 feet from the bottom
2 000 feet from the sides and a thousand
feet from the tops
i've got a lot more great lessons
planned here on the free pilot training
channel
so if you haven't already be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell notification
and if you'll hit that like button for
me on your way out that'd be cool too
we'll see you next time